foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
Advance your high throughput workflow
with sample preparation and automation
this webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series the seventh in the
series I'm Susie Valdez of lab roots and
I will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
Thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about Thermo Fisher
Scientific please go to thermofisher.com
so let's get started before we begin I
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
First participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located on the right
of your screen
you can also participate
and submit as many questions as you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing these presentation
just click on the help desk button
located at the bottom of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby
I now introduce you to today's speaker
first Hannah Saunders a manager at the
clinical sample preparation r d at
Thermo Fisher Scientific
joining Hannah will be Dr fan Liu a
staff engineer in the systems design at
Thermo Fisher Scientific
and finally Lily manly a scientist level
3 clinical sample preparation r d at
Thermo Fisher Scientific for a complete
biography of our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the left of your
screen
welcome to all three of you you may now
begin your presentation
hi thank you so much for joining our
webinar where we'll be discussing
accelerated High throughput workflows
Advanced with automation my name is Lily
manly I'm a scientist 3 for Thermo
Fisher Scientific with the clinical
sample preparation R D team in today's
webinar we'll have Hannah Saunders and
fan Lou discussing how we can accelerate
High throughput workflows advanced in
automation
through today's agenda we'll be
discussing first sample collection needs
applied to SARS cov2 we'll then have
Hannah Saunders discuss saliva and high
throughput workflows followed by
automation for sample preparation will
then be following with a topic
discussion around advancements for
sample transfer and at the end we will
open up the floor for a question and
answer session
sample collection for surveillance and
ongoing research is absolutely critical
there is recurring testing needs for
schools governments nursing homes
prisons and one-time testing needs for
travel and border control long duration
stays like cruises and hotels and short
duration events such as concerts or
pre-departure air there's a need for
convenient and non-invasive sample
self-collection methods that meet an
overall low cost must be easy to use
from sample collection to results and
should be pretty fast when processing
thousands of samples at one time
currently many of these techniques rely
on sub-optimal methods that may impact
Downstream results
nasopharyngeal swabs which are collected
in viral transport media can be highly
invasive and can cause sneezing a
coughing reflex and they're really not
suitable for self-collection the
alternative method for collection with
SARS cov2 can be anterior nasal swabs
which which can also be stored in viral
transport Media or saline this method
although less invasive can still be
moderately invasive may cause you to
need to blow your nose it can be
self-collection enabled but it may cause
bleeding both of these techniques
require a swab stored within the tube
that can cause issues for Downstream
processing within the lab's workflow by
moving towards saliva we offer a
non-invasive sample collection technique
that can be preferred by most users
especially for repetitive use there's
two different types of saliva with
saliva collection we offer stabilized
and raw saliva collection devices for
the particular needs
I'd now like to introduce Hannah
Saunders a manager with clinical sample
preparation for Thermo Fisher Scientific
where she'll be discussing saliva and a
high throughput workflow for viral
detection
hi everyone uh thank you for the
introduction Lily uh as she mentioned my
name is Hannah Saunders I'm a manager in
the clinical sample preparation group
for uh r d here at Therma Fisher
Scientific and I will talk to you about
our saliva collection offerings in the
high throughput workflows for viral
detection
so for RNA extraction in qpcr to further
enable saliva as a sample type we
developed the specimax saliva collection
kits the kits are available in both raw
and stabilized collection configuration
both kits are compatible with our magmac
spiral pathogen to nucleic acid
isolation kit and the viral RNA from
both configurations has been tested with
tacman SARS Kobe 2 assays that use rnasp
or MS2 as an extraction control
a little bit more about the specimax
saliva collection kits this slide
summarizes the defining characteristics
for both versions of the kit
each kit consists of an easy to use
funnel cap and a tube for supervised
collection the six mil standard tube is
compatible with many commercially
available automation racks the Raw Tube
is suitable for use in heat and
activation protocols for viral
inactivation the stabilized
configuration contains one milliliter of
the stabilization solution that is
capable of in activating SARS cov2 the
raw device is suitable for collecting
one to two mils of raw saliva and the
stabilized device
presents a collection volume of one
milliliter
viral nucleic acid from saliva after
storage in the specimax device was
tested for both options the stabilized
device enables shipping and storage for
up to seven days at room temperature the
stabilization is achieved using a
non-toxic detergent solution that is
compatible with disinfectants including
bleach some other methods use
guanidinium-based products that can
release cyanide if they're mixed with
sodium hypochlorate based Cleaning
Solutions such as
so next I'm going to talk a little bit
about the stability of the saliva that
is that is collected with the specimax
saliva kit the following data
illustrates the stability of raw and
stabilized saliva samples collected
using specimax and held at room
temperature for 10 days
for both studies the saliva donors uh
there were forced Laboratories used the
sample was spiked with inactivated SARS
cov2 at each time Point 200 microliters
of the saliva sample was put into the
reaction containing about 5 000 copies
of SARS Kobe 2 and it was processed with
the magmax viral pathogen 2 nucleic acid
isolation kit on the Kingfisher Flex
after nucleic acid isolation qpcr was
performed using tacman assays with about
a thousand copies going into the qpcr
reaction the kit includes three assays
that Target SARS Kobe 2 genes and one
extraction control which is the MS2
the graph on the left shows the data for
raw saliva the graph on the right shows
the stabilized saliva
on the x-axis are three covid genes and
the MS2 bacteriophage extraction control
with each gene Target the four donors
are side by side the y-axis is showing
qpcr CT values the blue diamond is the
day one stability the orange Square
shows day five the green triangle is day
10. notice that all three time points in
this graph are overlaid by donor and
Gene Target
for most donors and targets the CT
values at all three days remain constant
as indicated by the overlaid colored
markers in both types of saliva samples
there is a slight sample to sample
variation
however the Delta CTS are within
acceptable values of about one CT
difference within the donor and Target
over the course of the study the CT
values for stabilized saliva are
generally lower compared to the raw
overall the CT values at day 10 remain
below 30 and all Targets are detected
so the next slide shows some additional
performance data for the stabilized
device
we compared a collection compared to
another on-market device device a in
this slide
fresh unfrozen Salida samples were
collected from 32 donors using both the
specimax stabilized kit and kit a a low
and a medium concentration of an
activated SARS cov2 was spiked directly
into the kits and mixed thoroughly the
saliva samples were then left overnight
at room temperature
the nucleic acid was extracted from the
samples using applied biosystems magmac
viral pathogen 2 nucleic acid isolation
kit and the saliva extraction workflow
on the Kingfisher Flex
quantitative PCR was performed using
tacman reagents to determine CT values
for the SARS cov2 in Gene and the MS2
extraction control the graph shows
device a in blue and the specimax
stabilized device is indicated by the
red dots donors numbers 1 through 32 are
on the x-axis the x-axis is divided by
SARS viral input with low input on the
left and the medium Spike input on the
right
the y-axis shows CT values for the N
gene on the top and the MS2 on the
bottom
cross 32 donors collected with the
specimax stabilized kit and device a
little variation was observed in the
engine Target CT after spiking with a
medium concentration of an activated
SARS cov2 at the lower concentration of
an activated virus the engine Target
indicated the kits a retain less
detectable virus than the specimax
stabilized saliva kit
as the saliva specimens varied
inconsistency in content some variation
in the ms2ct values was observed this is
expected due to Natural donor to donor
variation however the use of Kit a did
result in higher MS2 CQ values across
all samples
the data showed that the specimax
stabilized kit shows better or
comparable performance than device a
across the donors tested with contrived
low viral concentrations when extracted
using the magmax viral pathogen 2 Kit
finally I would like to spend some time
on viral inactivation
for our studies we we use heat for the
specimax raw collection device and we
also looked at the capabilities of the
stabilization solution for viral
inactivation in the stabilized version
of the device additionally We examined
the extraction reagents themselves for
their inactivation potential
for the purposes of this discussion I
would like to focus on the specimax
stabilization solution
we perform studies to examine the
capability of the specimax stabilization
solution to inactivate several types of
viruses including SARS cov2 we were able
to achieve greater than a 4.5 log in
activation of stars Kobe 2 in our
studies
so the left side of this slide shows the
viral panel that was selected for an
activation studies viruses selected
represented varying characteristics that
might alter the susceptibility to an
activation enveloped non-enveloped RNA
double-stranded DNA genomes the
segmented genome
Etc
the viruses were prepared at high titers
and exposed to the specimax
stabilization solution or to phosphate
buffered saline as a control condition
the samples were then tested via plaque
assay in an appropriate cell line for
detectable live virus indicated by
plaque formation
cytopathic effect or CPE produces
plaques on a stained cellular modulator
mono layer and Tighter can be calculated
based on plaque count
volume added and dilution produced to to
calculate a value of platforming units
three serial passes passages were
conducted to confirm no viral particles
remained
the representative plaque assay images
on the far left show the viruses tested
with the specimax exposed samples on the
left side and the PBS controls on the
right as you can see we did not observe
any detectable infectious virus
particles in the specimax exposed
samples as indicated by the intact cell
long
the right half of this slide shows an
inactivation experiment conducted using
live SARS cov2 for this study we tested
freshly made species stabilization
solution as well as a solution that had
been aged to approximate about one year
of time
We examined a 30-minute exposure time
and a 60-minute exposure time
viral CPE was detected right out or just
below the limit of detection of the
assay Which is less than or equal to
1.47 times 10 to the 2 tcid 50 per ml
the PBS process controls read between
1.47 times 10 to the 7th and 6.81 times
10 to the sixth tciv50 per ml
the difference was calculated and
reported as the level for stars Kobe 2
in activation which is greater than 4.5
log 10 tcid 50 per mil by specimax
buffer under all conditions tested in
the study comparable results were
obtained with aged and unaged specimax
buffer both exposure time is produced
greater than a four log in activation as
determined by the tissue culture
infectious dose a greater than four log
in activation is considered high based
on a media recommendations and a
guidance statement from public health
England in 2021 that was specific to
SARS Kobe 2 Laboratory Testing
for more information on these viral
inactivation studies conducted with
specimax please see our webinar that was
recorded in November of 2021. with that
I'll close and return control to our
moderator thank you
thanks so much Hannah for reviewing the
specimax product specifications With
viral intactness and inactivation I'd
like to continue this webinar with
discussing some costly problems or
perhaps some pinpoints or pinch points
that customers might experience with the
high throughput labs and workflows
specifically there are costly problems
with sample prep sample preparation can
make up approximately 60 percent of a
lab's given workload it can you know
there's a big need for a robust sample
prep process that helps
re-evaluate that workflow and reduce
that workload on the uh on the operators
by increasing reproducibility
this can also help be achieved
with high throughput and automated
workflows we can increase consistency
produce a significant Time Savings and
also increase productivity in the
workload and specifically the workflow
including sample preparation we can
reduce variability between runs we can
have a faster time to answer compared to
culturing techniques and with Thermo
Fisher solutions that I'll discuss in
the slide following we can enable high
throughput and scalable workflows as
well
Thermo Fisher Scientific offers our
Kingfisher automation Solutions which
enable anywhere from low medium to ultra
high throughput workflows low to medium
throughput we offer our Standalone
compact bench tops our team Fisher Duo
Prime system for medium to high
throughput which can extract 96 to 24
runs per event we offer our Kingfisher
flex and Apex systems and for our ultra
high throughput we offer our Kingfisher
Presto system which can be equipped to
handle robotic most robotic or liquid
Handler systems
the newest of our Kingfisher magnetic
processor instruments is our Kingfisher
Apex purification system this system is
cloud enabled and has an intuitive
touchscreen interface with an optional
network connectivity it offers Heating
and Cooling blocks as well as a 96 24
and PCR format within the system the
system enables storage tube elution and
illusion into small volumes as well it
also has a UV light within the actual
system for decontamination between runs
this Kingfisher Apex purification system
is a high throughput purification system
for mid to high throughput Labs can be
can have scripts that are easily
downloadable from the cloud and it's a
very simple workflow navigation to any
labs needs
I would now like to introduce fan Lou a
staff engineer with Thermo Fisher
Scientific with our systems designs team
where he'll be discussing automation
advancement for sample transfer and
he'll also be introducing the newest
line to our Kingfisher product the
Kingfisher special track sample transfer
system
all right thank you Lily for the
introduction my name is San I'm the
staff system engineer uh working for
thermal fissure scientific supporting
simple prep so today's talk is about
automate automation advancement for
sample transfer and we're introducing
these bestie tracks system
so here we would like to introduce Kim
Fisher's messy track sample transfer
system which can help you uncap your
sample handling potentials uh the specie
track system is really an affordable
solution to automate decapping recapping
sample tracking and Sample transfer so
this the system features Advanced
robotic Technologies for increased
throughput and efficiency it also
features tip to while sample tracking
for improved traceabilities
also the system can work in a closed
system a closed door
environment that will support the
increased safety and staff welfare
um the paper the precise pipetting also
helps improve the consistency and
reproducibility of the results as you
can see on the image on the right it's a
system that can handle
192 samples from the airtight sample
tubes do a 96 deep well plates in 40
minutes
so with that let's jump into the
technical details
here's the inside look of the system as
you can see on the picture on the right
it's all the sub modules of the system
as you can see on the front there's uh
uh tubes loading on the racks waiting to
be processed and also the system
features three main robotic modules one
of them is the robotic arms which can
help pick and place individual tubes to
be processed also in the back we can see
there's a decapper module which is in
charge of two uncapping and recapping
whilst doing that it can also do the
barcode scanning to track the tube
information
uh once the tube is decapped it can be
processed by the Dew preparers on the
right which can load multiple types of
steps and deliver the samples to a 96
deep well plate armpit
and also I would like to mention that
the system can work under a closed
system behind the closed door when it's
working it features like a hip-hop
filtration for safety and the tips can
be ejected Into The Biohazard Waste
things below the deck
so the spicy track system also features
uh increased consistency consistency and
accuracy with sample tracking uh within
a system there's sensors that can
automatically scan the barcode on the
tubes uh for tracking within the
software I can scan both 1D and 2D
barcodes and we have advanced robotic
technology to increase this throughput
and efficiency was decapping uh while
it's decapping and scanning the barcodes
the software tracks the sample to Wild
destination uh in real time which is
really easy View for the user and reduce
the error and increase consistency
to do that we only need one technician
to initialize the ram
here let's look at some other key system
performance with a increased consistency
and accuracy on Precision paypaling So
within the system we have dual pipetters
which can actually allocate 10 to 1000
microliters of samples into Wells and
also the sample with varying viscosities
can be handled with the corresponding
aspiration and dispense modes which can
be easily selected in a software
also the user tip will be removed and
eject below the instrument DAC for
safety Biohazard Waste Disposal
also uh it's optional for the user to
pause the system to remove the waste
during the ram
and also as you can see on the table on
the on the left it's showing the
Precision and accuracy of the system
from 10 to 1000 microliter
um
Also let's look at some other key system
performance in terms of time saving with
species tracks automation
so in total we have a 85 percent to
reduce on processing time compared to
manual and also 95 time reduction uh
comparing to manual
um and also also the sample can be
transferred with high precision and
accuracy we have optimized and preset
parameters for various sample times
including a vtm and saliva so as you can
see on the table on the right which is
detailing the comparison between a
manual accessioning and also the
Kingfisher special track system the
total setup time for speci tracks is
only two minutes uh well typically
manual is taking longer and of course
for if you consider the total sample
processing time it's only 42 minutes for
Spacey tracks well it can be as long as
271 minutes for manual and also worth
pointing out is that once uh the system
is set up within the two minutes it's
totally walk away time for the user so
there's really no Hands-On afterwards uh
comparing to the manual ones
uh next let's talk about the specimac
compatibility on specie tracks so I like
to highlight some test results for the
compatibility study conducted both
specimax uh stabilized tubes on specie
tracks system so the spacing Max
stabilized saliva kit includes the
validated barcodes labels that's
predefined which is really friendly to
the specie track system which ensures a
really high reliable barcode reading and
also this um as you can see on the right
there's a checkerboard pattern that's
what we use to study the uh
cross-contamination so the samples was
placed on the specie track system in in
that checkerboard pattern alternating
samples containing and not containing an
inactivated uh SARS cov2 samples
um and then we use the system to process
uh these samples transferring 200
microliter from each specimen to the 96
default plate and the recap each tube
and from our study we find that there's
no Well to Well cross-contamination also
uh we processed reprocess those tubes
manually afterwards and we didn't find
tube to tube contamination
cross-contamination either so that's all
thanks to the working principle of the
system that we have deal paper working
at the same time while other samples are
closed and we also features HEPA
filtration and negative pressure while
it's working
lastly I want to talk about the uh
process flexibility with flex tube
compatibility so the specie tracks
system as what we saw before is fully
compatible with specimax uh tubes which
includes both stabilized lava and Ross
Lava Tubes but it's also compatible with
some other tubes it's an excellent set
on 5 and 10 mil transport tubes with
screw caps so uh there's more
possibilities down around if you have
other tubes that's not seen here please
contact your sales representative for
additional details so with that I would
like to turn back to Lily
thank you so much fan for reviewing the
detailed specific
offerings from the speci track system
with that I'd like to close up this
webinar by discussing the full sample to
answer solution provided from Thermo
Fisher Scientific
with Thermo Fisher Scientific specimax
saliva collection kits both stabilized
and raw we offer simple non-invasive
collection of your viral material for
Downstream applications by using the
speci track sample transfer system we
are able to easily transfer the material
from the collection device to the sample
plate which can be processed on a
magnetic particle processor such as our
Kingfisher Apex or Kingfisher Flex
magnetical particle processing systems
with any any mag Max nucleic acid
extraction kit such as our mvp2 nucleic
acid extraction kit Downstream detection
can be processed with real-time PCR
systems such as our applied system Quant
Studio
here at Thermo Fisher we offer solutions
for whichever lab for whatever labs are
needed we offer easy options to fully
customize the needs of each particular
lab here's a systematic of how we can
utilize one Kingfisher special track
system to support a high throughput lab
needs with two different Kingfisher Apex
or Flex systems and four different PCR
detection systems
with that I'd like to give a big thank
you to our sample prep Automation and
Engineering r d teams from Thermo Fisher
Scientific if you'd like to learn more
about sample prep automation please do
visit our virtual Booth I'd like to
thank also the lab Roots team for
allowing us to present here today at
this point in time if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
just click on the ask a question box
located at the far left corner of your
screen
let's get started
the first question coming in
looks like it's for Hannah what is the
collection volume of specimax
so
um thanks Lily the specimax lava
collection kit for raw saliva can
collect between one and two milliliters
of saliva and the stabilized kit has one
mil of stabilization solution and a
indicator line for you to collect
another milliliter of saliva to be mixed
with that stabilized solution
our total of 2 millimeters
great thank you so much I have another
question for you
what is the difference between the
preservative and specimax and kit a that
you listed in the slide deck
um so the stabilization reagent uh just
looking at what's printed on the um
customer facing documentation for Kit a
contains reagents that have acute
toxicity again and eye irritation that
can be harmful to the user if inhaled
ingested or if it comes in contact with
your skin or eye the systematic
stabilization solution is a
non-hazardous virus and activating
stabilization agents that's compatible
with disinfection protocols including
bleach and it doesn't contain any um
particularly harmful ingredients
great thank you so much
this next question is for fan what's
best what separates best attracts from
other liquid handlers
thanks Lily that's a good question so
these pictures bestie track sample
transfer system is enabled to decaf
recap in the session samples for full
work Solutions so with liquidity science
hip hop filtration and the UA
decontamination abilities on these
specially tracks stand apart from
current on Market Central transfer
system which might only enabling and
robotic
um the uh
meant to be compatible for mixed by
Circuit Labs Solutions Upstream of
sample processing Kingfisher magnetic
particle processors such as Kingfisher
my support APAC system
all right great thank you so much that
is all the time we have for today I want
to thank you guys so much for joining us
in today's webinar
um we appreciate it thank you lab roots
and thank you Thermo Fisher Scientific
for giving us the opportunity to be here
today
I want to thank Ms Saunders Dr Lou and
Miss Manley for their time today and for
your important research and before we go
I want to thank our audience for joining
us today as well and for their
interesting questions I'd also like to
thank our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for sponsoring today's
webinar questions submitted today or
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand for two years until May 4th
2024 and lab Roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye-bye